welcome back to the rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens following the drop of
quantumania we've got a few questions
lots of ideas all of mine revolve around
the quantum realm one of my favorite
parts and what interests me most was the
quantum realm scene as we don't really
know much about it but from Janet Hank
and Scott's perspective before we knew
the quantum realm was really accessible
via magic and just pin particles we
didn't really know about its life the
hierarchy their system or the customs
and now that Kang is presumably dead and
Cassie has now created a device that can
allow people in what does that mean for
Earth 616 in the quantum realm I think
during phase six we'll be using the
quantum realm as a sort of safe Zone and
ushering people into it that have been
displaced due to all those Kang variants
as a reminder originally Cassie hope and
Hank created a subatomic Hubble
telescope for the quantum realm which
sends a signal and collects the data the
signal is picked up by Modoc who pulled
them into the quantum realm and then we
jump to the end of the movie where Kang
sent a signal back to that device to
escape out of the quantum realm and in
doing so the device has the algorithm to
send and return people back from the
quantum realm so long as they have the
tech to do so I assume we'll upgrade
this device later and make it bigger and
more efficient but for now we know
Cassie has a device to look into the
quantum realm and allegedly send and
transport people back in the movie
Cassie is very much an activist and is
always looking out for the smaller guys
while her father is taking on global
emergencies and hope is feeding the
world Cassie's helping the people in her
City who are not a threat for suffering
from various systemic issues when we
first see her she's arrested for
protesting and she clearly feels
horrible but she sees what she
indirectly did to gentaurus people when
Modoc found them she just wants to help
people I can appreciate having a young
voice of reason and MCU who's active in
politics to a degree you know like
protesting voluntary and lobbied what
have you we haven't really seen it yet
and it feels very much grounded rather
than like in space fighting things I
think the Guardians of the Galaxy's
holiday special really opened her eyes
to where do these people go when their
planets are destroyed New Asgard was
able to take their people somewhere else
but for planets without the same
resources do they just like perish I
don't think there's no better time to
introduce Cassie and her activism she
just wants to find resources for
everyone maybe as wakanda did for the
entire nation they use vibranium to
build Outreach centers she'll be helping
those in the quantum realm using Pim
Tech after Kang Dam polish the quantum
realm and made himself the ruler after
killing almost everyone they're clearly
short-handed I think a big signifier was
mentioning the quantum realm device can
collect data and find people so now
Cassie can check on jantora and the rest
of the people in the quantum realm and
figure out what remaining resources they
might need in order to rebuild HIM Tech
has already helped the quantum room with
Hank's ant colony without that ant
colony they wouldn't have been able to
take on King Hank's ants were also
sucked into the quantum realm and fell
into a Time expansion field and lived
thousands of years over the span of a
couple of days they built a technocratic
civilization they're determined and very
smart they basically made a city of
their own in the quantum realm if
they've already built a civilization
this place could be light years more
advanced than anyone else's so they
probably still have that ant mentality
of building and working together to make
things more efficient if they apply what
they know to the quantum realm they can
assist in repairing the Damage Done by
Kang in no time Additionally the ants
can help transport things from the earth
616 to the quantum realm could you
imagine if they went back through that
time expansion field or just lived on
learning from each other the medicine
and Tech they would make would be
magnificent
they'll be ahead of the wakandans and
could share resources with us another
nod to why the quantum realm could be
the safe zone for future residents could
you imagine the ants with vibranium oh
my God we just have vibranium ants
running around if we take a look around
phase six I think this has potential to
start around Thunderbolts or the
Fantastic Four movie I say Thunderbolts
because we see how Valentina Allegra de
Fontaine wanted the vibranium in wakanda
my next guess is she wants to see what's
within the quantum realm if the ants are
making massive Discovery she'll probably
want that too and what if instead of
being exposed to cosmic rays in outer
space the Fantastic Four are actually
people living within the quantum realm
exposed to a lot of quantum energy that
would be nuts but still a sound
possibility which is why I think this
could be happening between Thunderbolts
and Fantastic Four ultimately I think
this all will happen before Kang Dynasty
when little interruptions and hiccups
start happening to people's timelines
and homes King the Conqueror and Thanos
are also not far off in terms of you
know killing and taking over at a large
scale I think if we take that
speculation and toss it up in the MCU
right now we get another nowhere on our
hands it's common that villains destroy
cities countries planets universe and
for those that escaped I think in this
case we'll be ushered into the quantum
realm and this is how I think nowhere
will be destroyed again this time by
Adam Warlock because in the trailer we
see in Guardians of the Galaxy root
jumping on him and warlock beating up
nebula and what I assume is nowhere I
think the high evolutionary will send
warlock to kill the Guardians and anyone
in his way and in doing so we'll destroy
nowhere displacing those citizens again
as the Guardians of the Galaxy they'll
take the people of nowhere to a place
the high evolutionary hasn't touched yet
Earth presumably because we don't know
if he's been to Earth yet in the MCU
there they'll meet Cassie and hope who
have now created safe housing one being
within the quantum realm I like it
especially a two for one that's exactly
what you get when you're playing Empires
and puzzles Empire and puzzles an
award-winning free-to-play Match 3
puzzle and RPG game and I love it just
match Shields of the same color to
attack the more you match the stronger
the attacks you can collect over 400
collectible Heroes available based
around different elements in every month
unique new heroes are introduced so
there's always something new to unlock
and I love new things to unlock in
between fights you can improve your
Empire by by leveling up your food and
iron production craft useful battle
items train your troops or even summon
More Heroes if you want to play with
your friends just join an alliance or go
toe-to-toe with other players in PvP
battles where you can get amazing
rewards I keep coming back to Empires
and puzzles because of the continuous
updates including weekly events like
Season of Love which is going on right
now seasonal love features five New
Cupid inspired heroes in 20 stages with
three difficulty modes test your skills
and earn rewards by completing stages to
progress through the event to get
started with Empires and puzzles click
the link in the description below or
download it from the App Store Android
or iOS I think we'll also start hiding
people in the quantum realm what better
place to hide than a place that's hard
to reach that's what I always said as a
child in the cupboards as long as we're
not hiding from Wanda again there's a
ton of folks we haven't met in the
quantum realm and I think their
superheroes already there waiting to get
out the Fantastic Four the Silver Surfer
hid in the microverse there's rumors
that the Scarlet Witch might be hanging
out after Multiverse Madness so the
chance that maybe Cassie and hope can
allow someone to hide there is probable
now with this Theory it does come a lot
of danger Kang the Conqueror banished or
exiled by his fellow kegs but like every
place the Multiverse is no limit to the
quantum realm when we open the doors
allowing people in we bring in all types
of people and I think this can be a
gateway to the scroll Invasion what
happens if someone who is actually a
scroll winds up in the quantum realm I
don't necessarily believe they'll be
World damaging compared to Kang maybe
they'll be a good scroll either way it
would be another world to infiltrate if
they are a bad scroll if their Scrolls
posing as Kang it could stir up a lot of
commotion with people believing he never
died or of a scroll Captain Marvel were
to show up and take over a lot could
happen there's been speculation that
even Janet is actually a squirrel and
what if now having access to going in
and out of the quantum realm she'll make
it her home base of operation as a
scroll I think we should pay as much
attention to her as possible to take an
L on my own Theory though a squirrel
posing as a hero or villain that we've
already seen inside the quantum realm is
a little far-fetched but squirrels
posing as Citizens and creating an
uprising I could see it's also possible
to scroll from Earth saw a hero we
haven't met yet and will pose as that
hero in the quantum realm and either
destroy it again or actually help it
I've posed this Theory before because I
think we'll be seeing a lot of
superheroes in secret Invasion that we
know from the comics that we just
haven't seen yet in the MCU without
transporting in and out of Cassie's
device who else can reach the quantum
realm we know basically all the Kang
variants can banish people there with
the use of Mystic Arts and pimtech we
know strange Wong definitely Wanda and
probably Agatha could presumably
possibly we could even get an America
Chavez so if we start to explore the
quantum real more we'll be opening the
idea to these folks Wanda and Agatha
having access to the quantum realm only
poses a threat because we don't know
what other witches are down there or if
there's a stronger magic presence for
Wanda to get a hold of genuinely I'm
sure Wong has seen or been to the
quantum realm and just doesn't care for
it overall I think there's also a good
possibility ghost can make her way with
the device Cassie made now if we know
ghost basically absorbed a ton of
quantum energy and when she would rest
she needed a Quantum energy chamber to
stabilize her now that Janet
sort of fixture if she were to walk
through the device Cassie has it might
be too raw and explode King's energy
core was finite if we don't know how
much power ghost puts into her face and
she could possibly make another
probability field now that's maybe this
is ultimately a theory but worth noting
her powers coming in contact with the
quantum realm could be disastrous
there's a lot of questions and theories
and we'll be answering them on inside
Marvel the Deep dive in our Theory
videos everywhere so keep an eye out for
them all make sure to follow me at Lulu
underscore Clemons not daschal who
sneezes follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thank you to Empires
and puzzles for sponsoring this video
download Empires and puzzles Now by
using the link below and a reminder that
our new channel the Deep dive is
launching Friday February 17th boss is
literally going in and dropping like
five videos at once daschle One Division
Loki all deep Dives a breakdown on when
trailers are lying to us which we all
kind of need an Insight on plus they'll
be doing a live breakdown on Quantum
Mania on the Deep dive Channel that's
insane here's a little preview to get
you jazzed up
hey y'all
[Applause]
in this vast Multiverse
hi I'm Eric Boss and this is new
rockstars the Deep dive in which I go
beyond hunting Easter eggs so try to
decode what the eggs mean is this Kang
variant truly surprised here or is he
performing a script that requires them
to act surprised
[Music]
initiating spin